peu de dix mille hectares réduisant sans
rendre la gironde continue de brûler
malgré la mobilisation des sapeurs
pompiers les incendies sont toujours en
cours et ce depuis mardi
de jour comme de nuit les pompiers de
gironde lutte sans relâche contre les
flammes
quatre soldats du feu ont d'ailleurs été
légèrement blessés la nuit dernière
les conditions météorologiques sont
extrêmes pour l'instant ces incendies
reste tout bonnement indomptables et il
demande
nous avons été interrompus avec julie
vitaly des reprises de feu menace de
nouveau les camping de la dune du pilat
les touristes avaient été évacuées par
précaution il ya quatre jours à l'est le
gigantesque incendie de landiras lui non
plus n'est toujours pas maîtrisé ils
sont agriculteurs viticulteurs tous
bénévoles ils veulent sauver leurs
terres leur village avec les moyens du
bord
dites moi à quoi ça sert
91 ans après la funeste rafle du vel
d'hiv les 16 et 17 juillet 1942 plus de
13000 juifs dont près d'un tiers
d'enfants étaient arrêtés par la police
française détenue au vélodrome d'hiver
avant d'être déportée à l'extérieur la
gare de pithiviers n'a eu droit qu'à un
simple rafraîchissement de façade elle
est donc très ressemblante à ce qu'elle
était il ya quatre vase
l'intérieur est en revanche totalement
remaniée pour accueillir une exposition
permanente sur 150 mètres carrés même si
le vel d'hiv a été rasé le murmure monte
encore
il nous saisit
ils nous étouffent
et n'en déplaise à des commentateurs se
faisant révisionniste ni pétain et laval
ni bousquet n'est darquier de pellepoix
aucun de ceux-là n'a voulu sauver des
juifs
c'est une falsification de l'histoire de
melody dans un tweet matic panneaux
écrits ne pas oublier ces crimes
aujourd'hui plus que jamais avec un
président de la république qui rentrent
au nord à pétain et aux 89 députés du
rassemblement national la france est
soumise aujourd'hui est devenue la
france s'indigne la france irresponsable
la france dé du bruit et du fracas sur
des polémiques en tous cas aussi grave
c'est abject c'est ignoble mes mots ne
seront pas assez durs pour décrire ce
tweet mais rappelons aussi qu elle n'en
est pas à son premier coup d'essai comme
le disait il y a une semaine et demie
quand elisabeth bande faisait y avait un
bon café et choisissez le mou rescapés
alors elle on connaît l'histoire
personnelle d'elisabeth bornes elisabeth
bornes fille d'un résistant juif déporté
à auschwitz a présidé la traditionnelle
cérémonie regrettant je cite que l'état
français soit allé plus loin que
l'exigence des nazis ça n'est pas être
patriote que de déchirer les pages de
l'histoire qui nous dérange de les
occulter ou de les amoindrir
et je trouve que madame panneaux au delà
de cette provocation
nauséabonde fera mieux de la fermer
c'est une tribune au vitriol contre
caroline cayeux ministre des
collectivités territoriales en 2013 elle
avait qualifié le mariage pour tous deux
des cinq contre nature des propos
qu'elle ne regrettait pas mardi dernier
sur le plateau elle tente de s'expliquer
avant d'ajouter j'ai beaucoup d'amis
parmi tous ces gens là et franchement
c'est un mauvais procès qu'on a fait
caroline cayeux du gouvernement avec moi
des propos extrêmement blesson je fais
partie de ces gens là mais je ne dis pas
titre individuel nous avons besoin d'un
acte politique fort à la fois
d'elle-même et puis du gouvernement le
président macron un programme sur les
questions lgbt
eh bien il peut être temps de
l'enclencher pour eux montré
effectivement de quel côté se
gouvernement ceux-ci caroline cayeux
ciel avait une quelconque j'allais dire
en quelconque honneur elle démissionna
d'elle-même mais puisqu'ils semble
qu'elle ne va pas c'est au gouvernement
d'être clair là dessus on lui rappellera
française je suis de ce genre que vous
condamnez les excuses ne sont vos rien
parce que elle donne le sentiment que
c'est sa pensée profonde